good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy
day
the
thursday i hadn't had a chance to
process this morning that it is the
thursday and that's just a very welcome
joy you haven't had a chance to process
it because you're coming off a major
mama victory that i think we should talk
about a major mama victory an mmv an mmv
so i have been working on sleep training
for the last few days because our sleep
schedule was chaos there was none it was
i think what people would consider not
good i just don't think you can call it
a sleep schedule because there was not
because there was none and so we started
sleep training so if you're a mama like
you know or you know you have a baby
that loves to sleep and that's not been
something you've had to grapple with
we're happy for you but last night
we got nine straight hours in the crib
nine straight hours in the crib
rolled for the win rolled for the win
world killing it rolled out here just
[ __ ] killing it so i'm feeling
refreshed renewed if you guys were on
breaking bread last night you know that
i was at the end of my sleep deprivation
rope breaking bread last night was a
motley mix of chaos we were both just
feeling particularly unhinged we like
didn't really abide by our google talk
that we like too but we got through most
of it by the end and i don't even care
because i think it was our best episode
yet especially because you could hear
rolls crying in the background which is
just a beautiful sound yeah i don't know
how much you guys can hear but you'll
find out on friday when the episode
drops on demand and of course as we went
live big news broke that chloe is
expecting a baby via surrogate
imminently christian one mr tristan
thompson and we are going to explore all
of that today but it was really crazy to
have to give your immediate opinion on
something without having time to process
no i know and people were like coming at
me because like my in the comments
because my overwhelming
overall like i think it's a good thing
um
and people were just like coming at me
like justin's not a good dad so we'll
get into all of that um but before we do
i have something to say and i know you
do too yeah and yours is way more
important than mine but you go first if
if mine doesn't go first then it'll get
lost yeah i understand because you're
about to break some like life altering
i'm about to break some bread yeah um
but the uh now i feel like people aren't
going to focus on mine because i've like
hyped yours up so i want to hear it uh
the pre-sale for my first three shows of
endless big news are out so that's red
bank new jersey new haven connecticut
and west hampton beach new york pre-sale
started for patreon members right now so
if you're a patreon member go get the
tickets if you want to become a patreon
member you can get tickets and then on
sale for everyone starts tomorrow but if
you'd like you know vip tickets close up
i would suggest becoming a patreon
member those are the first three shows
of the end log final leg by the way i
need help with like your brain like your
word brain okay how can i help okay it's
the final leg of n log like make
something about you know
branding marketing yeah yeah yeah and
leg
yeah
that's a little like too close
no like yeah and leg it's the final end
leg
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was the staccato version yes
so three shows there are more coming of
course like portland i see you see
actually i have a question for you sorry
to like i hate i feel like i always put
you on the spot when you're announcing
tour news because it's not all ironed
out and here i am asking you to iron um
roughly how many more shows do you think
you're going to do 12 to 15. oh hi a
decent amount okay great yeah that's a
good amount yeah through this year and
then 2022 will have been the year of end
log never to be seen again except maybe
at a tv coming to you soon ugh i would
love that that way i can memorize it
backwards and forwards like all my
favorite specials um so yes patreon
members now tomorrow friday at 10 a.m
eastern time they go on sale for
everyone now that my boring news is out
i think we should talk about
honestly in the words of camille grammer
now we've said it yeah that's your new
favorite quote i know because
what was i watching oh ultimate girls
trip when they were talking about um
it's actually like a dark quote because
now we've said it about russell about
russell being abusive yeah so it's like
actually like not a good thing to quote
it's kind of like sophie's choice like a
common phrase
as a flashback yes and now we've said it
and ever since then it's just like
sometimes you have and now we've said it
yeah wow okay so now i'm going to say a
major life update for me
which is that i am moving
out of new york city
i'm moving to florida
and i'm very excited
and i'm very emotional it's very
bittersweet because you know all new
things obviously but i'm gonna miss
me
you know it's been 15 years that i've
been here my
half the family is here theo
theo is here there i mean the studio is
here and i just want to say right off
the bat the toast isn't going anywhere
the most important thing is that not
only is the toast going absolutely
nowhere and we have a patreon episode
coming out we know you guys have a lot
of questions so we record an entire q a
like an hour long thing about it um
that's going to be on the patreon right
now like more in-depth you know how i'm
feeling about everything what this means
blah blah blah questions that i think
you guys might have um but the most
important thing is that the toast is not
going anywhere i built a studio in my
new house so that we can do seamless
remote episodes we have that stunning
new integrated interface yeah so it's
just going to be like nothing ever
happened except i'm going to have a
whole new life and a whole new lease on
life yes and so the most important thing
is obviously the toast this changes
nothing changes nothing if anything i do
think the last couple of months have
been a little scattered for us just
because of baby and move and just like
personal stuff going on so i do feel
like once you're settled we'll be back
in a really good groove and i think
moving forward we'll probably be more
scheduled and organized than we've been
in the past simply because like now we
have to be you literally don't live here
yeah right i'm excited for all of the
change that it's gonna bring to the show
in terms of like the content and like
what you know the change it's going to
bring out in me just being like lighter
lighter obviously if you guys have
listened to the show you know that like
the city is not my favorite place and i
just don't like living here and it's
always i've always liked not been a city
girl like i talked about a cleveland day
i want a farm children lifestyle but
like the last few years in the city have
been particularly terrible
and i just don't want to live here
anymore and i'm not going to listen you
don't need to explain yourself like you
are making the best choice for you and
your family yeah literally this is that
scene from kardashians
when they're on the phone with the
lawyer and chloe's telling him what to
say she's literally i'm making the best
choice for me and my family yeah it went
viral on tick tock oh that's why it
stared into your brain
so all the details are on patreon i'll
be sharing more um i'm moving like in
the next few weeks so these are gonna be
the final studio shows but like i'm
going to be back you will see me in this
chair so many more times and also when
claudia comes and visits me we're gonna
podcast from my studio and then she
never has to go home because she can
work from my house and you know i
actually just figured out my first trip
it's really soon because i have a
wedding in florida in august so i'm just
it's on a thursday and then i'll stay
for like a month with you
can't wait just make sure that my
bedroom has a king size bed we talk
about this on the patreon we talk about
the things that i need to have in my
house on the patreon so that claudia
will come and then because olivia also
lives there and olivia's home stunning
bedroom freezing big-ass bed apple tv
snacks kayla we have this whole combo on
the patreon but in the last few days
i've been thinking of other things that
i am going to get that are going to
entice me tip
the scales in my favor well the scales
are just so in your favor because if i'm
staying with you we're going to podcast
and so like why would i not stay at your
house if the podcast studio is in your
house yeah um
but i don't know i need to be dazzled
because i'm very upset about this whole
thing like this whole move i think it's
disgusting it's offensive you'll hear
claudia's thoughts on the
podcast and also it's funny because we
actually haven't spoken about it a lot
with each other because it's just like
too sad and i'm like 100 in denial 100
in denial claudia doesn't like change so
the way that we deal with it is like we
just don't talk about it so talking
about it on the patreon episode that is
live now if you're listening to this is
the most we've ever talked about it and
our feelings about it yeah no it was
definitely like awkward and painful and
not not cool of you but we had to have
this conversation
and i just want to let you guys know
that my move is brought to you by
roadway and their new company move muuv
move it is so awesome i have worked with
roadway on every single move so far they
did this studio they did this studio
they did all of my new york city moves
they did olivia's florida move they have
a new company called move and it's
making moving even easier and even
smarter
roadway and move have the most amazing
movers they get everything done honestly
some of you would think like moving
would be so
tart
but some of my most relaxing days have
been during moves like everything was
taken care of i remember one time i got
a pedicure during a move this time i was
just popping in and out just checking on
everything but honestly they had it all
in hand they're so careful moving can be
so
physically laborious and emotional and
emotionally and so they handle all the
physicality of moving so that you can
just focus on the emotions and
look forward to this new chapter in your
life and not have to like stress about
the actual physical moves yeah like i've
moved without movers from roadway and
i've moved like by myself and i can tell
you like movers is the way to go movers
is the rate to go roadway is the way to
go and now with move you can move even
smarter even faster even easier and with
my code jackie ashrae 10 you can get 10
off of your move which if you're a lot
moving and that's it it's a great deal
so jackie austria10 at move muv you can
check them out on instagram muuv
underscore us
a sister company to roadway we love
sisters here
together and honestly i don't know
this whole what you would do this whole
thing would be even more stressful if i
didn't have a moving company that like i
just love and trust and have worked with
and don't even have to sweat it it's so
true by the way like the physically
moving is
it's literally back breaking work back
breaking but you don't have to break
your own back because they have people
who are equipped and talented and
skilled and they make it easy and
everything comes the way that it left
you know so that's the big news um i
just really like i can't stress enough
like i don't want people to panic me
neither that's why we didn't even want
to make like a big deal of it because
like literally nothing is going to oh
and by the way if you listen to the
podcast nothing has changed oh yeah it's
like never too bad if i never said it
you probably wouldn't have even known
and also you would have known because
our audio quality is about to become way
better way better no more ambulances
like things maybe just for me on your
end for me you might hear a light breeze
a bird chirping in the wind yeah the sun
shining on the lake i can't i know it's
very exciting it's disgusting so um
patreon.com
patreon.com for more details how we're
feeling about everything you know what
my plans are
and
that and really how this is all
affecting me and how it's all affecting
claudia i think everybody needs to be
really you know sensitive towards
claudia tiptoe around her right now this
is a hard time for her because she
doesn't like change even though i feel
as though
it sounds like more
change change identity than it is yeah
for sure i honestly like we talk about
something else like i hate this i know i
know but i just wanted to let everyone
know but it's really like nothing's
gonna change around here you know that
the toast is my favorite thing on earth
and we'll be doing it till the day we
[ __ ] die right and nothing no
amount of distance between us it's true
it's gonna change that and absence makes
the heart grow fonder so i think you're
about to fall even more in love with me
i know sometimes like when you go on
vacation or we like podcast remotely
like it's so nice to miss you it's true
is that why you're doing this yeah
because i want to miss you and love you
even more if that's possible that's
sweet
so yeah that's what's happening uh
nothing's gonna change and we have a
great show for you we can say that we
have a great show for you because of the
news that broke last night there are big
stories wednesday's episode from
yesterday we didn't have time to do dear
toasters and they are there's one deer
toaster that's like one of your biggest
pet peeves something that people do and
i can't wait to hear your take on it
like i wonder why you think one of my
biggest pet peeves maybe not a pet peeve
it's something that you find so
unethical
oh do you want to guess
something i find so unethical when it
comes to dating in relationships
reading someone's diary yes i meant how
did you know that because that's we're
so simple you're so seen pat you go so
yeah somebody wrote a diary and found
something they didn't like and that's
what you get that's what you get when
you delve into someone's feelings like
of course that's literally the
definition [ __ ] around and find out yeah
and like just like we have we were
talking about intrusive thoughts like if
anybody ever
was able to see your intrusive thoughts
somehow they would think that you were
psychotic that's what reading a diary is
that's what reading a diary is like
inner most thoughts and feelings it's so
[ __ ] up wow okay looking forward to
that but i think without further ado we
need to jump right in because the top
story of the day is just taking the
world by story it's on the tip of my
tongue the teeth the lips the tip of my
tongue the teeth the lips
without further ado
where are you
you are home and sleeping
oh stress and boys we love you
come back to work
come back to yad aunty
it's just a shout out to bryce and
strassen always always in our hearts
without further ado it is time for the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toes
yes you
you yes you you yes you are
i have nothing to say we're on summer
break early that means
i'm free
our first story khloe kardashian and
tristan thompson are having a baby boy
via surrogate say sources chloe and
tristan are expecting a son multiple
sources confirmed to page six absolutely
her rep
so
last night news broke on tmz that chloe
is expecting a baby be a surrogate any
day now if not already but i do think
it's not here yet same because chloe's
statement was like it's coming she said
via her team we could confirm true will
have a sibling who was conceived
okay not here yet okay and
i love that she's telling us the
conception date because you know that's
what everybody is so worried about was
it pre or post theo's revelation theo
being the son of his mistress yes chloe
is incredibly grateful to the
extraordinary surrogate for such a
blessing we'd like to ask for kindness
and privacy that so that chloe can focus
on her family
so
let's go through the timeline
yeah
chloe found out about
theogate which is such an unfortunate
coincidence can i add um in january
the conception date or like the
implantation whatever you call it when
was that november
got it okay so the timeline is clear but
what's and
baby's conceived in november when does
he arrive 10 months later which is uh
november september 1 september yeah
maybe end of august maybe end of august
yeah okay
so the timeline adds up obviously she
didn't have another baby with tristan
knowing what he's done she's not dumb
but what's weird is that when they were
freaking out about theogate kim said if
this isn't a sign to have a baby with
this person i don't know if the baby
wasn't all right if it was still just a
twinkle in their eyes an idea an idea i
mean maybe you know sometimes like
when people get pregnant especially i
feel like with the kardashians like
their later pregnancies the first one i
feel like everybody knows and everybody
shares but then later
you know she might have not told her
sisters yet because the surrogate would
have only been about one month pregnant
and sometimes you don't tell people till
like three months no for sure but i feel
like she would have told kim
you don't tell people but you tell your
sisters especially a family like that
like everyone knows everything that's
true and i do feel like that's
definitely an oversight on like the
editing
like if they're trying to hide something
here but i don't think kim i mean i
guess they do like act their way through
everything sometimes but i don't think
kim was not
no that was like a raw moment i agree
that's what i mean i mean i guess we'll
find out like exactly when the baby
arrives when the birthday is etc and
we'll be able to put it together but i'm
definitely under the conceived in
november she said it i'm under the
impression that this was long before she
found out which makes the whole thing
even more heartbreaking but it's
important to remember at the end of the
day like
this is a child and a child is a
blessing and it doesn't really change
chloe's life that much in the sense that
she's was always gonna have to be a part
of tristan's life the co-parent and they
were gonna have to do that until true
was 18. so why not get another baby out
of it we know she wanted more children
so i don't think this is like that crazy
and i think it's amazing honestly like
tristan no offense is irrelevant the
more he [ __ ] up like the less chloe
will have him around and like what she
wants is more kids and he makes
beautiful babies yeah and
she like they have a sweet family and
like chloe and her babies like that's
going to be it for her and instead of
having to like you know meet someone new
and go through this whole process again
like
just get a brother for true yeah and you
gotta bother for true and now you also
saw tristan's true colors
if i'm sure we talked about this on
breaking bread last night i'm sure
january and february were really hard
for chloe like learning this information
with a baby on the way but i'm sure
today chloe is nothing but excitement
over the moon excited it's right
everything that she wants and tristan is
still like the irrelevant person
that he was before and would have been
even if it was only true in the picture
so at least chloe has another baby which
we know she's wanted so badly and she
really did want it with tristan yeah so
you know what it's really not that bad
and we're all just processing all this
information now because we just got it
but you're right like chloe's probably
had a place of complete peace with this
and yeah the information has been
processed for chloe and so i think today
chloe is doing great and is just so
excited and i was saying i'm breaking
red last night i'm so excited for new
mama energy from chloe like
maybe and it's again like she's having a
baby similar time to close to kylie like
their kids are just going to be so
simple and the girls always say they
want to have their kids close in age so
i think for chloe it was very important
to have a sibling for true while true is
still little as opposed to you know
waiting and seeing who she meets and
this is right like she got what she
wanted and i'm so [ __ ] happy for her
and as claudia said i'm breaking bread i
have toxic positivity when it comes to
children these days and it's so true
they're just such a blessing and a
bundle of joy and just i'm so happy for
chloe and i know that like the headlines
make it seem delicious because anytime
it's chloe and tristan it's like
yeah but
i think chloe and i think even before
her and tristan got back together like i
really don't think
she cares she cares about him aside from
him being true's dad right
i think she wrote him off and saw who he
was a really long time ago but it's just
her situation yeah and she's making the
best of it and i feel like maybe at this
point she's looking at tristan as like a
sperm donor
yeah just a really involved
famous sperm donor yeah but at the end
of the day like chloe gets to expand her
family true gets a brother and her life
her day-to-day doesn't really change
like tristan
is gonna co-parent with the new baby the
same way he would true so it's all the
same and tristan's busy he plays he has
other kids like i don't think he's
really up her ass that much
he was for a while on the show he's up
her ass i hope she doesn't let him near
her ass anymore like i think she knows a
statement that their relationship is
like exclusively co-parenting gorgeous
gorgeous and you know when you take the
emotions out of it it probably makes it
a lot easier to co-parent in a rational
and like fair way and i wonder how the
business man feels about all this i
wonder how shaq will feel about it yes
so let's talk about the alleged
boyfriend that chloe has businessman
beau um
that must be exciting like you know you
really can't have it all it's not like
she's pregnant so she can't like go out
on dates you know surrogate affords a
level of luxury it's like oh i can
literally have my cake and then come
home and deliver a baby you know yeah
it's kind of everything yeah the more i
hear about surrogacy the more interested
i am like i think it's so i know that's
not why people do it because like being
pregnant is such a blessing yeah but the
way that i'm just like at the place i'm
at in my life i'm like oh my god have
someone do it for you that's
it's not even about where you're at in
your life it's just about like who you
are
to your core which is like painiverse
change of earth like pregnancy is all of
those things but i'm also a really
family-focused girl right so right
obviously kids is important to me of
course like the idea of like literally
being impregnated and giving birth is so
far-fetched to me
it's crazy i know
i know it's crazy so i'm just learning a
lot from the kardashians yeah no i think
this is beautiful news i am so happy for
chloe happy for the whole family it's
going to be such a simcha
and and i guess we're gonna see a lot of
this unravel this is also and i don't
think they planned it this way but this
is just the kardashian effect like we
just got the trailer for for the
september or whenever the show's coming
out season two also i think that this
has successfully been the best kept
kardashian secret of all today yes
because even when it was not a whisper
not a june item about his famous family
has another baby coming you know that's
so true because when i think of like the
biggest kept secret i always think of
kylie's pregnancy but every day towards
the end like people were it was an open
secret yeah
it just wasn't confirmed by them ever
but everybody had speculation you know
people saw the stroller and the name and
things delivered to her house
not a soul whispered about this that's
actually so true it's obviously i think
easier to keep a pregnancy secret when
you're not the one who's pregnant right
so comparing kylie to chloe but you're
right this is definitely the best kept
secret there must be probably five
people who know then
yeah yeah the sisters also we did some
name predictions on breaking bread last
night and i just want to share our
predictions
so first we were looking at chloe's
grandparents names and she has a grandpa
named arthur so i thought perhaps we
have an arthur and then that made me
realize that arthur george arthur george
arthur george sucks the most successful
they came to me in my sleep last night i
was like arthur george well that happens
like we're so like i'm so like the show
was like so literally like in our dna
like i will literally think of things i
should have said think of things i'm
going to say the next day like in my
sleep no me too i was like that's why
it's arthur george
okay and then my other prediction for
the name because obviously robert is a
very meaningful name to them it's
chloe's dad's name it's her brother's
name and it's chris's dad's name i don't
know if he knew that so i think it would
be a robert jr but that's rob kardashian
so robert junior jr
rjjr
roger
that's my prediction roger thompson
roger third trimester thompson roger
that thompson roger roger thompson the
raja juror what is your prediction for
the name by the way
when it comes to pop culture like nobody
slays like me like i know everything
i'll challenge you to a debate till i
die
when it comes to baby name predictions
not only do i like literally not care
like how many [ __ ] names there are
like you're not right [ __ ] like no one
is ever right there's literally millions
of names and most celebrities make up
names nobody was ever going to guess
true because it wasn't a name until true
okay except that true is in their family
okay you know what i mean no one was
ever gonna have
apple
paltrow right so i don't like guessing
celebrity names because i find it dumb
and a waste of time like you're not
gonna get it and even if you like are
close like good for you like what do you
want a prize
i don't know i just after having named a
human i'm very invested in the process
that's fair maybe i'll feel differently
but your name is actually
i don't recall if i was this invested
before i had the burden of naming me
because it really is a burden oh my god
it's so hard look at kylie right
right right
right except we saw a baby's legs in her
instagram stories they're just
love that we did get a little sneak peek
uh so
that's the big news of the day i'm so
happy for chloe just why the i feel like
this is such big news it's cause like
nothing really shocks me anymore you
know like we've really seen it all here
at the morning toast um but this is just
something so unexpected it's nice to be
surprised again thank you chloe and
that's also because i do think a lot of
big news is
sort of dulled when there are rumors
swirling the first time you hear it
you're like no that's not true then you
hear it again you're like oh i already
heard that and then they confirming
they're like we all knew right the fact
that this was just out with the
confirmation it struck you right that's
kind of like what's happening happening
with emily radakowski yeah it's like
known that her husband has cheated on
her and they're filing for divorce but
literally i went to make it a story
today and it's not been written up i'm
like so how do i know this like everyone
just knows it so when the inevitable
like instagram post or
pr statement comes out we won't be that
surprised right but if that statement
had come out without you ever having a
thought about it oh my god i would be
shook to the core yeah so this was
really like a bombshell a bombshell
kardashian's like 20 years into the game
still
on top still on top still keeping us on
our toes
are you ready for our next story i am an
attorney has ignited a nasty feud with
erica jane after putting an offer on her
former home one of the lawsuits involved
in the many ongoing lawsuits against
arkajin has bizarrely announced one of
the lawyers sorry has bizarrely
announced he's attempting to buy her in
tom's former home ronald richards the
former trustee attorney on tom's
bankruptcy case and current attorney in
a 5 million lawsuit against erica
announced on wednesday that he and his
wife put a 6.9 million dollar offer on
the pasady in a california state is it
just me or is that a great price for
this house right with the chapel he
quipped that he hopes to have erica's
deposition there along with other
players in the case and wants his
followers to see how the victim's money
was spent by the star and her estranged
husband he also said we will use it as a
public forum on first amendment
activities something erica and her legal
team are strongly against they want
secret hearings and trials not public
scrutiny
i find this like so weird like this
guy's so invested in this like of course
i guess you want your lawyer to be like
on your side but like he seems like he's
like a personal vengeance this is just
like taking it a little far and like
don't you have to have depositions in
like an office or i guess he's gonna
make his home his office and then
legally can have depositions there and
make it like into some sort of museum
because she said uh she wrote back to
him on instagram uh oh and the fact that
this is all happening on instagram makes
this whole twitter illegitimate uh how
are you going to get this museum past
the homeowners association i think they
like their privacy she also said i knew
you and your wife were super fans this
really confirms it
no this is definitely weird
she said to his wife and then comment
does it bother you that your husband is
obsessed with me honestly like
her responses are kind of on like fire
flames like this
this is just like weirdly personal you
know yeah
this is very bizarre
and it seems like his real grievance is
against erica
when up until now there's really no
proof that erica had any knowledge of
any wrongdoings and definitely didn't
have any wrongdoings herself right
up until so it just feels weirdly
personal and like he's airing a personal
grievance
in his job and the whole instagram of it
all makes it even more weird to me like
if that was my lawyer okay let's say i'm
a part of the the people who are owed
money a settlement i hire this lawyer
he's trying to win me and a couple
people five million dollars um and i see
him on instagram like buying houses and
getting into comments with like getting
messy it's so messy it's really weird
yeah
and i don't think
it'll end up happening so he's gonna buy
the seven million dollar home for what
it's a nice house it's still it's by the
way it's a very unique house like yeah
but
why did i think it would be worth way
more than seven million dollars
um
that's a good question i
i do think when you sell a home at
bankruptcy like it's like the bank takes
it like is that what it is i don't know
what's happening i don't know
he was the trustee of tom's
yeah so does that mean he's responsible
for listing the home and buying it that
seems like he's literally like cutting
some corners i don't know this is so
confusing and beyond my
leveling of it yeah you know but that's
true i guess what was it 6.9 mm-hmm does
seem kind of low for like a pasadena
estate and in this economy right with
the chapel and inflation and the
the gardens the greens yeah i'm just
looking at this pool remember when she
had that party out there that party like
didn't fit at that house you know what i
mean it was like a turn it's a very long
house yes it's like you're right it's
narrow yeah but that just might be like
the lots in pasadena right um so this is
so [ __ ] weird and honestly i'm
incredibly confused yeah me too but
i feel like stuff like this this like
clown show that's happening in erica
jane's life actually works and works in
her favor because again it's like we get
distracted we're like oh this stuff is
messy it's not that serious you know
people are making it personal true and
it desensitizes you to the crimes that's
actually so true and also where the [ __ ]
is tom
he's in that home and he's just like
gonna like die there
i guess so i mean because his family
like erica said wouldn't step up won't
step up does he have kids yes
that's crazy yeah
very
very weird end of this story like not
the end it's just like a weird bookmark
derailment no and you're right it does
make erica look good like
that everyone around her is acting
chaotic like clowns this is clown [ __ ]
yeah
yeah and i get wanting to like stick it
to tom like i get it but this is like
weird and erica's right like it does
feel like stick it to him in the
courtroom right it feels personal and
weird what you're gonna have deposition
in her master bedroom like it's just
weird yeah it is like he's kind of like
obsessed yeah
just a fan just a fan are you ready for
our next story which claudia hand chose
because she's obsessed with everyone
involved and she just talks a lot of
smack but at the end of the day it's
because she's a fan of course and and
stead congratulates tark el musa and
heather ray young on their pregnancy
well it's it's heather's pregnancy i
just want you guys to know that like
after having been pregnant it's
heather's pregnancy agreed
he congratulates tariq on his wife's
pregnancy yeah and and that used to not
bother me like when people would get
like we're pregnant mitch what did you
do no but other people would be like no
you're not she is and i was like just
let them be pregnant right i got it
i got it you're apologizing to the mamas
message received yeah
and and stan congrats congratulated them
on expecting their first child together
he said huge congratulations you too he
commented on instagram thrilled for you
all if you don't remember he was
previously married to christina
hack and stead al musa who is tarik says
twice did him an aunt did her and aunt
ever get married i think they maybe just
dated they were married oh damn both
enstead and el moussa were previously
married to hack who is now married and
dick and is now dating renee zellweger
even though i don't know if they're
still together they were spotted once
but like i like to imagine that they're
happy together um and christina is
remarried so
let's just let's take this step by step
the first is that tark and heather are
engaged they were trying for they're
married
sorry i mean are they pregnant yeah
they're pregnant um they posted you know
some jugalicious content and we're happy
for them you know baby is a blessing
like we were saying
um but now let's talk about the ant
instead of it all cause him commenting
on his ex-wife's ex-husband's new wife's
pregnancy the enemy of my enemy is my
friend right so there's obviously bad
blood between the ansteads
of course the former they're also known
as the end stuff there was a divorce and
this is just there and he went over to
team el moussa there's so many people
involved and i was actually thinking
about this as i fell asleep last night
like
when and when claudia thinks about the
el moussa ray young's as she goes to
sleep at night when
tariq al musa and christina hack and
stead el moussa got divorced if you
would have asked me like who would have
ended up in the messier situation like
no doubt would it have been tariq like
there was that incident where the police
were called to their house he took a gun
and ran up into the mountains like
screaming at everyone i was like tarik
is going to be the one who ends up like
like in the crack den or something like
he's obviously the one who's unwell and
that's why they're getting divorced
i just did not see like him literally
like stable same girl engaged like so
traditional in a sense and christina i
think is on her third husband there was
and
tarek
there was another guy and now there's
this guy hack hack
yeah
it's just no it's like you know how
people count sheep when they fall asleep
like claws
[Laughter]
claudia thinks about the web the love
rhombus and it gets so confusing that it
tires out her brain she falls asleep no
it's true like even though i'm so
invested in the story i still can't even
like fully tell you all the names of
people christina's been married to yeah
because what's hack's first name i'm
gonna say jonathan but i just made that
out
let's see if the articles there's kind
of like the element of mystery that i
have around this story also makes it so
exciting you know what's the mystery
that i don't know and i have these
people's names oh
and there's also something weird with
that you are right she married
she like really
yeah she secretly wed joshua hall
earlier this year
who's that right
right who the [ __ ] is that and the weird
thing is that hall oh hall is hack
wait christina hack secretly married
fiance joshua hall
so maybe hack is her maiden name
got it but hall
jackie this could put me to sleep jackie
it gets even crazier hall
has a sister
who has the podcast who used to have a
podcast with heather ray young okay wait
it gets more confusing because now i'm
looking at the wedding license
and
christina
el musa hacks
also has a maiden name here muir singe
so she was married to someone named hack
so hack isn't a maiden name
unless mercinge is just her middle name
no
no
i just can't believe there are girls out
here who like spend so long looking for
love like and christina's out here like
getting married four times like i'm
actually jealous she must be like a
delight you know to get so many men to
marry you like it's not easy to get it
one time it's not easy to get it once
right like it was one of the hardest
things i've ever done and she's out here
doing it
yearly annually
yeah and i just think that's impressive
and honestly i have a lot of respect for
it i do and we're happy for heather and
tariq truly we are it's nice like and
then their show and like i think this is
what both of them want this is their
dream life they're living it heather ray
young is like living her fantasy like i
don't think she thinks anything that's
happening to her is real like
she got her own show which you know
coming from a
ensemble ensemble show where she's
really not the most interesting or not
the main event or whatever um
this is a dream you know and she's got
the man she got the baby like
and their recipes are on us weekly like
that's a dream for heather it is and i'm
happy for her i really it's really nice
to see people living their dreams it is
it is really nice to see people living
their dreams like knowing like
everything that's happening to them is
exactly what she wanted and tried for
like that's such a blessing mm-hmm and a
baby's a blessing too i think that's the
end of today's episode a baby is a
blessing it is
are you ready for our next story
tom brady is opening up about how his
wealth is the hardest thing about
parenting no i know it's
it's really hard
i feel for him you know like
so hard he was on a podcast spotify's
drive podcast which you know that part
we do love which isn't as popular as a
morning toast and he thinks that his and
giselle's wealth is the hardest thing
about raising their children he said
quote we have people that clean for us
we have people that make our food we
have people that drive us to the airport
if we need that we get off a plane and
there's people waiting there for us and
we get ushered in
he said
this is so sad oh my god
he said that's my kids reality which is
the hard part to say guys this is not
the way reality really is what can we do
about that what he's saying is he's like
i'm giving his kids this unrealistic
expectation for life and like how do you
raise normal children in that situation
by the way i understand exactly what
he's saying like
so fly commercial what's stopping you
right
move into just a regular stucco house
take the tram to the airport yeah take
the subway tom yeah but then you know
what then they do that and then we come
here and say why are they doing this
when you have a limo
so true um i do understand like what he
was trying to say like when you grow up
when
tom and gizelle didn't grow up like that
so you know how do you teach your kids
you want to give you want to give
everything to your kids you want to give
them the best of the best the best
schools the best everything but then you
also want to you know have them grounded
in reality like i get it it just
it blows my mind that it didn't cross
his mind to shut the [ __ ] up like we're
literally headed for a recession like
people are unemployed everywhere like
literally like
nobody feels bad for you sorry no i
don't think he's trying to make people
feel bad for him i think he's just
talking about his life which is what you
do on a podcast and like telling someone
to go on a podcast and then shut the
[ __ ] up about like the things that they
think that they think about like i think
that this is the sort of quote that
taken out of context sounds a little
like tiny violins but he's just talking
about his life and like yeah he's
raising kids and the hardest part is
that like we have an unrealistic life
and like him and his wife he talks about
how they grow up she grew up in a rural
brazil the farthest state south with a
very small kind of farming town as a
very simple girl he grew up in a
middle-class family in california where
his dad worked his ass off and like
those circumstances allowed them to be
the people that they are and like their
kids are growing up in different
circumstances and that makes it hard to
raise them as the people that they want
them to be i don't think he's trying to
say feel sorry for me no you're right
taken out of context like if i were to
sit down and listen to a podcast where i
want to learn about tom brady like
obviously i wouldn't find this so like
hilarious um but in the context of a
page six story like it does sound so
dumb
but she's sharing his life i guess
that's fair that's totally fair and like
that's what we want people to do on
podcasts and even if you have like you
know a thought that's not
sympathetic
or relatable or relatable like you're
tom brady you're not supposed to be
relatable no but also like everyone is
entitled to like say what they want yeah
but also it's like say you're you know
you and your wife like grew up and you
are proud of the people that you are but
you have these circumstances and you
want your kids to grow up the same way
like really how do you parent them in
the way that you were parented when they
have all of these things that are so far
beyond reality i think there are ways to
do it honestly you know what comes to
mind for me which has weirdly like
always stuck with me it's such a random
niche reference but um
when
lisa brenna like first joined the show
and she made her daughter's work at that
deli even though they were like models
and like superstars um there are little
things you can do to like ground your
kids in reality or to at least let them
know like
how blessed they are like when crystal
to and um i don't know why all my house
my my references are from housewives but
when crystal and garcelle did
thanksgiving at um
a soup kitchen you know like there are
things you can do not to show your kid
like this is what real life is like but
just to be grateful for what they have
you know so there are ways for sure i
mean this is definitely something i
struggle with with theo you know
i'm
giving him everything like this
unrealistic life and he doesn't know
that it's not like that for other dogs
and so i actually really really relate
to this he's enlarged 100
not like other dogs yeah
so this is actually extremely relatable
for me i probably will tune into this
podcast and take notes yeah anyways just
like always celebrate big stars going on
podcasts that's true that's true that's
a lesson here and like talking about
themselves in ways and opening up in
ways that they don't normally do because
if you know if they get a lot of [ __ ]
they're not gonna do it anymore that's
true that's bad for the industry and you
know that's the kind of content you get
from a podcast like tom brady was never
gonna open up about this on like jimmy
kimmel you know
no he was gonna tell like a stupid story
about like what his kids did on the
plane right totally
literally
are you ready for our fifth and final
story um
and i'll just tell you the headline
instead of trying to like explain what
it is without saying what it is you know
because noah schnapp has revealed where
him and doji cat stand after the dm's
drama so
we spoke about this on breaking bread
last night because if you don't know on
breaking bread we have a really fun
segment called the sixth story award
where we claudia and i each share a
story that didn't make it to the fast
five but that like we feel personally
invested in and claudia talked about
this doja cat noah schnapp drama beef
like beef if you don't know dojukat dm'd
noah schnapp privately he's from
stranger things if you don't know that
either which he's 17.
and i guess they had like followed each
other they had some connection that made
her comfortable to reach out to him and
she was like can you set me up with i
forget his name joseph joseph one of the
new castmates on stranger things he's
29. um
and noah schnapp was like sending uh
doja his instagram like dm him whatever
then noah schnapp posted the private
instagram stories
posted the private messages from him and
doja on his instagram story like blowing
it up and dojo then like attacked him
and people were like dojo chill he's 17.
he's a minor um she basically called him
a snake he's not socially aware and
that's some snake [ __ ]
and then everyone turned on doja because
like why are you coming after a kid he's
17 like chill um
joja ended up losing a couple hundred
thousand followers and no snap ended up
gaining like a million which is such
like a weird thing like to unfollow
someone for like people people on the
internet like wielding their unfollowing
like a weapon like we don't [ __ ] care
like on yellow like we'll be fine like
you say this is not an airport you do
not need to announce your departure
so
now i guess noah snap is revealing where
they stand because people turn to on
doja cat even though like i did
understand her frustration like he's a
kid so he didn't know better but like
can anything be private yeah no i
understood where both of them are coming
from but
it's just not like the biggest deal it's
not like the gm's are so embarrassing
and like he is a kid and yeah probably
not socially aware like to realize you
know the biggest star in the world dm's
you just keep that to yourself like be
cool about it no he's [ __ ] inside and
he's posting about it so what did he say
was the update between them
so he's setting the record straight on
where they stand he said a tick-tock
video with her song playing in the
background he said guys everything is
all good i apologize and i still follow
her and love her music no hard feelings
okay
i'm sure like
in private he's like this is so dumb and
i hate her but i'm sure she's saying the
same thing right right but um and i just
want to know what joseph quinn thinks
right well so that's like kind of you
know the
the untold story of this entire saga is
do they get together
definitely not after this yeah i don't
think she showed her in like a great
light it's you know this compassionate
understanding
loving person yeah it's like oh if you
mess up and do something socially
unaware like right you're done you're
done this is just like such a weird song
like i didn't have that on my bingo card
this year like noah schnapp the kid from
stranger things beefing with jojo cat do
you know who noah schnapp was before
that yes only because i don't want
stranger things but because he
is also like a tick talker okay
okay like he's i think the most probably
one of the most followed kids from that
show not millie bobby obviously but he
has like a huge social audience he might
have even been like a digital king
before
he's like i don't really know but he's
like got millions of followers got it
cool good for him and now you know now
even more he has to do he's got another
mill
under his belt that's just the teeny
boppers are fighting you know
but she's not a teeny bopper right she's
just like funny you know i just want to
say like there's probably nothing in the
world doji could do um for me not to
like her like yeah i just find first of
all her music is supreme like literally
you cannot show me another person making
better music
and her social media personality she's
just funny she like understands internet
culture but not in an annoying way yeah
in a condescending way like it's just
funny and i just and she's literally
gorgeous like i will never not stand
dogecat no i agree and also sometimes
like being oh i'm sorry and she's jewish
do you know that i knew that she's
partial yeah we'll take it it counts but
being that like funny internet person
who's like candid and speaks their mind
on everything like you are bound to get
into situations like this where you say
a little too much you take it a little
too far and it's just like the parts of
doing business the price of being funny
on twitter and instagram and sharing
your thoughts and feelings is that the
[ __ ] truth [ __ ]
now let's dive into deer toasters our
advice segment that we usually do on
wednesdays but we didn't have time
yesterday and i'm glad we do have time
today because now both out both episodes
are going to be like a delicious hour
long delicious
patreon too for i don't know if you guys
like left when i made my announcement
and went to patreon and are now coming
back or if you're waiting until this
episode's over and then you're going to
patreon how would you do it i would
finish the episode that's just because
i'm like ocd like i finished what i
started and then i don't like to like
read two books at once no i agree i
couldn't listen to two episodes at once
no that's like psychotic let us know
what you did yeah let us know um dear
toasters is our weekly advice segment
you can email us dear toasters gmail.com
it is totally anonymous and you can
write in about anything from friendships
to work to wedding to hygiene we've got
some good ones today they're all kind of
different and i'm gonna read them you
know what i was just thinking yeah like
when chloe moved into her new house
she probably knew that she had a baby on
the way and like that moment was
probably even more sweet like she kept
saying like this is going to be me and
true sure every home and it's like this
is my family's home it's true yeah
that's a good point and i just now if we
go back and rewatch a season like with
the understanding that some of the older
episodes and the final episodes like she
knows she might be having a kid like it
changes things
yeah
um that's like finding out the ending of
like cheddar island and then re-watching
it again like knowing the truth you know
it's the exact same thing it really is
and you know what that's the lesson is
like
all roads lead to shutter island it's
all about perspective
and then like you go back and watch
shutter island and it's like so [ __ ]
obvious like how dumb are you you didn't
realize that um and maybe that'll have
the same thing with kardashians on hulu
yeah all right
no i did hear that the first season was
directed by martin scorsese so it makes
sense no i heard that too
hey jackson claude hey my friend needs
your beautiful stunning and smart advice
on this quandary she has found herself
in okay we'll do our best sally has been
dating her boyfriend jack for nine years
they just bought a house together and
they are very much otp however jack has
been in a bit of a slump lately and to
try and help him out of it he started a
diary
sally got curious and in the spirit of
trying to understand what's going on and
help him through she snooped in the
diary she found he'd been writing daily
about the things he's grateful for i.e
grabbing his favorite coffee going on a
walk but then he mentioned he's grateful
for his chats with a female co-worker
who sally does not know what should she
do now reveal that she snooped and asked
about it try to casually bring it up
absolutely nothing and take this to the
grave help signed a snooping sally and
her toaster friend
absolutely nothing and take it to the
grave okay however
but i would just
try and think of you know what are these
chats about it's not like he's saying
i'm grateful for the sex with my
co-workers
so like maybe you could
maybe you could engage with him in some
chats and try and be that person for him
but you cannot act on the information
that you found in a diary unless you're
so disturbed by it that you're going to
end your relationship period unless it's
like a committed murder right and in
that case like just go to the police and
leave take the diary and run yeah yeah
so this the lesson here is to not i'm
all for snooping like if you have a
suspicion i don't think like i think
reading people's text messages is like
really invasive but like i don't think
all snooping is bad yeah no but also
text messages are different because
that's like outward behavior that's
something that you're putting out into
the world for the world for another
person
you're they're almost like actions
whereas diaries are just thoughts and if
you saw every single person's thoughts
if you could read someone's mind you
wouldn't like what you saw yeah and
that's what a diary is no it's really
[ __ ] up so the lesson here is not to
read diaries but now that you have this
information um
let
just keep it in the back of your mind
like obviously don't act on it or do
anything but like if he starts to
exhibit like you know weird you know he
starts disappearing or like you know you
know where to look first but for now a
chat is a chat and maybe you're right
like it's indicative he's looking for
like a deeper connection like he's
having a meaningful chat with some
random [ __ ] at work and it makes him
feel seen maybe you're not making him
feel seen or maybe like whatever he's
going through he feels like he can't
talk to you about it but this girl at
work like they're able to talk about
this thing like i would just try and
find is a slippery slope by the way like
my girlfriend doesn't understand me if i
read this like i would be like
all consumed by it and i would be
[ __ ] shook and like oh my god there's
another person who's like having
honestly an intimate relationship with
my boyfriend because having all sorts of
chats enough for him to write in his
diary you don't even know this girl like
it's a level of intimacy it's not like
cheating or anything but they're
connecting on a way that you guys aren't
so
if you want to take some action i would
try and find a way to connect with him
and be that person for him um
and just try and focus like try and fill
that fill that role and i have to say i
don't really feel like there's anything
nefarious going on with
the girl let me tell you why because
even though like a diary is extremely
personal there's something like if you
were having an affair like i don't think
you would ever write it down like
there's something about putting it into
the world that like makes it real and i
feel like affairs are things that like
people keep in their mind you know like
it almost seems like the fact that he
wrote it means it's innocent you know
yeah even though it's a personal diary
like it's just kind of crazy to be like
oh i had such a great time with my
mistress today like right no no i agree
with that but like what would you do oh
well
okay so ben's writing he's having
meaningful chats with sally at work um
i'd probably kill sally
i think that would solve all everyone's
problems yeah
no i don't i don't know what i would do
um i don't think i would ever admit to
reading someone's diary because that
says so much about you it's like it's a
really [ __ ] up thing to do so i
wouldn't admit it but i'd keep my eye on
[ __ ] sally for sure while also
nurturing and working on my relationship
yes that's what i would do
i was joking about the murder i feel
like transferred if i ever get to a
place in my life where like i'm like
framed for like
some sort of crime like all they have to
do is comb through these episodes where
i say i'll kill random people like
i
need to erase my entire like youtube
hard drive yes but on the other hand
you've also said you would take numerous
bullets for people that's true so i
think they all what what they'll give it
she take it away they balance each other
out right and also i i actually do think
about this often the fact that um
our podcast is
in the comm i know this sounds crazy the
fact that our podcast is in the comedy
section and like it's an art form
there is a law like
if someone wrote a song about like
killing someone and it ended up like
matching up with a murder you can't use
the song lyrics as evidence because it's
art wow i saw an sv episode about that
so i don't know if that's like entirely
legally true you know what it sounds to
me like like we're artists the law is
reason free from passion actually yes
the law is reason okay the law is reason
free from passion projects
that's the law canva pro write it down
um
so yeah i often think about that all
right next up hello claudia and jackie
i'd love your advice on a predicament
i'm in over a year ago my aunt gave me a
fur coat of hers since i was moving to a
colder climate and i needed warmer
clothes
i knew it wasn't my style but i took it
anyway to be nice and in case it would
be nice she said it wasn't her style
how bad could it be
she was
taking it in case she was suddenly
invited to a formal event that she
needed a luxurious coat for
fast forward to now i've never worn the
coat so i decided i should sell it on
poshmark when i was looking at the
original cost i was shocked to see that
it was worth 3 500
i've had this thing where thousands of
dollars just sitting in my closet i
truly thought it might be a couple
hundred dollars max now that i know that
that's the cost is it wrong of me to
sell it should i try giving it back to
my aunt granted she lives in another
state and i don't know when i'll see her
again what's the right thing to do here
wear it
yeah by the way i don't think you can
sell it without a permission that's like
extremely [ __ ] up and and maybe she
gave you the jacket like as alone and
then like when you when she maybe you
move back or she moves somewhere close
to you and she wants her coat back and
you sold it like you can't sell it
without her permission by the way it
might be the sort of thing that you
can't appreciate right now or like have
no use for but like that is something
that is a forever piece keep it
keep it
yeah well also you just can't sell it
because that's wrong it's not yours to
say it's not yours to sell it's yours to
wear
and it's like a thoughtful gift and
maybe it's like a family heirloom and
also these things increase in value over
time so like the longer you wait like
the more it'll be worth
don't sell it for real
okay final one hey jackson claude
congrats on the baby the tour the spritz
tick-tock fame and everything
so my problem is that my roommates
don't shower enough and they smell yeah
for example this weekend we went to wine
country in texas and we were out all day
in the texas heat wine tasting so
obviously when we got back i wanted to
shower and not smell gross but they
think changing clothes is good enough i
will repeat it was the texas heat over
100 degrees with no breeze now our
airbnb is gonna smell and the same
happens at our apartment back in the
city i know you guys addressed a smelly
friend on dear toasters before but how
do i address a woman and a man who
refused to shower more than what seems
like twice a week not that now i'm
saying
now i'm not saying i i'm sorry now i'm
not saying hair washing i'm just saying
body watching because we live in [ __ ]
texas and it's summertime any advice how
to be as non-confrontational as possible
thanks ladies that's horrible i'm glad
you made the discrepancy between because
like
we're not i don't really believe in
judging other people for how frequently
they wash their hair but washing your
coochie is a must a daily mask
especially in the heat yeah um
in summer like for me
i would just not live with these people
you know because it's like you're
fundamentally different like yeah and
you can't change people and you can't
like say you need to shower more you're
not their parents right like they want
to live this life like that they want to
go around being a smelly person like
that's their prerogative they're adults
making a conscious choice not to shower
and it's not like i think it's always
different when someone has like a
a problem like a smelling problem like
they shower but they smell like people
have different sweat issues like this is
just a choice not to be hygienic
and that means that you two like the
three of you are so fundamentally
different as people you probably
shouldn't live together i don't think i
don't think you should renew your lease
i think that you should find other
roommates like there are things as
roommates and living co-living partners
that you all need to really agree and
you don't have to have a conversation
about it but you have to have the same
sort of values like temperature right in
the house
music volume do are we having parties
are we not having parties right what
kind of home what kind of vibe and i
would say hygiene smells showering would
be included in that yeah i don't think
you need to make a big announcement or
tell them this isn't working out like
they can still be your friends and then
you can go to wine country where you all
smell and then you go home to your fresh
sheets and you smell good and your new
roommates smell good too i would just
extricate myself from the living
situation
yeah i agree this is just like people
being different
people are different right and we're
nuanced complex human beings
and finding a roommate is one of the
hardest things in the world like someone
you really jive with you can never live
with someone who's like your best best
best best friend because that's like too
toxic you know like has to be someone
you like like there's a balance to
finding the perfect roommate and you
have not found that so keep looking keep
yeah keep looking and maybe uh
for the meantime like stop taking your
friends on outdoor texas wine tours in
the heat like go bowling it's air
conditioning yeah but they probably
wouldn't shower after bowling go to the
movies and that's nasty at least the
sweat is their own germs
like did you shower when you got home
from your birthday
or did you get into bed with your
bowling stove okay you know what i
didn't even think about it because like
i went to the club afterwards and i
didn't get home till four so i wasn't
even i was thinking no i got straight
into bed you're right and that's
literally disgusting but my sheets
haven't changed since then okay
but i actually did not think about that
that's actually disgusting you know i
was like when we were bowling i was like
i wonder how many people here are going
to shower when they get home probably
not should i write in the group chat and
survey the group yeah no i think it
would probably be like
15 showered because you went home you
and zach went home my friend margo went
home i think the three of us showered
yes but everyone else went to the club
and was out really late
and like drunk no one's gonna take a
shower when they get home and people
probably forgot that we had bold like
you know yeah
um so that was your toasters again if
you ever want to write in it's dear
toasters gmail.com
that was our show that was the final
episode of the week we're back in studio
tomorrow we're still on summer break
we're back in
monday so it's monday tuesday wednesday
of next week and then we are officially
back summer break is over um summer
break yeah what what summer break it's
last two weeks like scattered episodes
we missed two weeks well we couldn't
tell people what we were actually doing
which was you were getting your life
together because you're moving to
another state so we called it summer
break and i'm like we missed two
episodes it's not a break we're missing
five total including next week yeah five
out of ten so summer break half summer
because we're on summer break
um but we couldn't say why because
jackie didn't want to tell him when
she's moving until tonight so
i was being creative and inspiring with
my summer break i think people felt
really inspired that's what we do here
at the morning toast thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning shows
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available to podcast and where podcasts
can be found spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i heard you cast box all
the places wherever you listen to
podcasts find out some morning chosen
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are hope
you guys have an incredible day an
incredible weekend we're back in studio
on monday we love you guys so much and
we will see you then bye tran.com
morning toast for all of the moving
conversation see you tomorrow on monday
bye
you